alors alors dû manquer rester avec elle
tu me disais c'est la bonne et bordel
qu'elle est belle on refaisait le monde
sur le canal de la partie maintenant je
voudrais savoir où tu te casses sur la
carte alors alors on s'est promis de pas
se lâcher alors alors et je crois bien
qu'on s'est raté ta changer de numéro
tu avais pas envie de me parler quand
j'étais appelé 1
alors alors est-ce que tu as fini tes
études tu avais plein rêve mais je suis
pas c'est une gêne vis de tout ce que je
voulais dire toi qui répondait présent
quand on parler d'avenir
ouais alors alors on devait faire le
tour de la terre tu sais moi ma balise
est encore prête et si jamais tu nous
revient est ce que je vais te
reconnaître faut pas qu'on laisse mourir
alors promesses non alors alors t'es où
vas tu mens c'est fou j'y pense chaque
jour je te vois partout ils disent que
tu reviendras pas que tu es mal à que tu
es mort j'aimerais que tu sois là pour
leur donner tort hier qu'elle tu deviens
tout le monde c'est vrai
s'appelle ans va saper l'andante alors
qu'ils braquaient s'il vient
tout le monde sait c'est vrai
ça fait longtemps du dr
j'ai cherché dans le quartier mais non
je peux
non j'ai demandé à tonnerre
a nouvelle tout le monde avec new jack
refuse tout l'été mais j'espérais tout
l'hiver
bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle c'est
alors alors tu es parti chercher ton
eldorado tout le monde à doha d'or en
ski fait un mort à mortes et peut-être à
bora bora en maillot ou anton signe de
thé blacks-là elle est trop long alors
alors recommencer ailleurs john sms ou
un pigeon voyageur il ya encore nos
taxes sur le banc lisible et entier
faute tu vois comme gill a changé oui
alors alors tu sais que je suis un peu
râle pas toujours du retard tu étais
jamais à l'heure à leur halo halo ya
comme une latence c'est plus que du
retard la cenap 5,1 alors alors des
nouvelles
même s'ils sont mauvais j'ai fait tous
les hôpitaux appelé tous les hôtes et si
tu en as marre d'imola en face caches tu
sais j'ai passé l'âge de jouer à
cache-cache alors alors que tu sors de
ta plan on suffoque dans la fente ont
six fois plus latente
j'en ai marre est entièrement le
dénouement est ce que ça te plaît de
savoir que tout le monde met en l'air
alors si moi j'ai su devient
ouais
ça fait longtemps
dis moi que tu deviens c'est vrai ça
fait longtemps rendu l'air
j'ai cherché un gars y est mais non non
j'ai fait le tour de la terre mais
j'ai vraiment
a nouvelle plus fort avec nos jardins du
tout les mêmes
j'essaie tout l'hiver les corps dit le
proverbe nouvelle tourmente athema
c
mais qu'est ce tu fais bien
c'est vrai ça fait longtemps ou
certaines longtemps alors il manquait
stud et bien c'est vrai ça fait
longtemps tu viens